I up you know that the paint doesn't get
dry on the five-year plan before Lee who
had a great view of what we ought to be
doing globally and he just felt that we
were lagging behind a bit in our global
initiatives and put together a group of
Trustees back then jonesboro Savio
tongue Clyde whoo Vikram Pandit etc who
began to think about you know what we
could do internationally today we have a
hugely successful operation and I'll let
me tell you about it so everybody speaks
about globalization and I I think if you
look at China if you visit China if you
go to other countries you realize very
quickly that astonishing things are
happening in the world they've happened
very rapidly and it's mostly economic
activity that is generating this huge
transformation of the world and then you
take bills area of Technology and how
that is a Gutenberg press kind of change
in our world we can communicate now in
ways that are utterly beyond anything
we've had before you put those two
forces together and you have a new and
different world that means any
university that's going to think about
what their fields are what work we do
what wait what we need to contribute to
the world how we educate our students
everything has to be thought through we
move very slowly deliberately we think
about problems for long periods of time
we look for as much truth as we possibly
can find in the in the rich mystery of
life and and but we always know that we
have to align ourselves with what's
happening in the world so how do we do
that in this new world we have lots of
great faculty who are experts in China
namerica global issues there they're
really wonderful wonderful faculty great
regional institutes and yet a lot of
faculty feel I think and I certainly
have felt this way that we need to get
out more into the world and see what's
happening so that we can adjust our
fields and then and think of new fields
so how do we help them well we set up
groups of faculty from different fields
we give them some funds what you're
doing that we've committed that creative
the Committee on global thought led by
Joe Stiglitz we've done a number of
things that are really good but the
other thing we have to do is figure out
what kind of presence we will have
around the world got great international
students and faculty coming here but how
do we get out of the world so we've
decided to follow the course of setting
up global centers we call them in seven
regions of the world by the end of this
year we will have seven up and running
Paris Amman Jordan Mumbai Nairobi will
open Beijing Santiago and and these
wheelie are staffed by very
sophisticated people in different kinds
of buildings but they're they're usually
small and the staff is there to help our
students and faculty work on real
projects with local institutions around
the world and we think that will be a
fantastic way for us to establish a
presence in the world great so I'm going
to go to have you talked about you
mentioned you know the three big schools
and you know the importance of those
give us a brief update on medical
medical school law school business
school and then we'll turn it over to
the audience for some questions guys
that business school of course is
thinking very in the future for the move
to Manhattan build and any time you do
that you naturally think through really
what is business school education and
research all about the school is being
led by Glenn Hubbard doing exactly that
law is always very vibrant that's my
field and
I love the law school I think it's doing
extremely well and filled with people
who are eager to work on these kinds of
global projects medical school is is
really a great success story underly
Goldman of a place lots of medical
schools but ours especially was very
financially challenged and we've
stabilized it lias done great work there
and now we're just in the process of
beginning to develop a very very
significant long-term plan for for how
to improve it talk about everything I
mean journalists at school really a
wonderful under nick lemon Social Work
Jeanette Takamura graduate school Carlos
Alonso Evan we've got we've got great
great leaders I mean just them to watch
the improvement of the schools and in
you know I said in the trustee meetings
years and years ago when you worked on
these things and just little silos until
each one of them got enough critical
mass and clout to where they became part
of a great university that now is rated
number four in the world so let's turn
this over to you I'm sure you have some
questions that you'd like to ask Lee and
if we have do we have microphones in the
audience you just want to get up and
shout oh there's a couple of microphones
back there but shouting works too yes
mr. president and mr. Campbell thanks
for being with us today in the papers
recently how are you doing well sir
thank you first even like what we see
the question no boys in the papers
recently there's been a story about the
Bloomberg administration possibly
inviting Stanford or Cornell or some
other institutions of no consequence to
open a
a branch campus in this city
specifically dedicated to Engineering
and Applied Sciences and as a
professional and technology yourself you
know what do you think we should be
doing to respond to this and are we
responding to this so i will let Lee
elaborate on this but let me make sure
first of all want to make sure you guys
everybody in this audience knows if
there was one person responsible for
making sure that we've got ROTC back on
our campus town was the member of the
Senate and really pushed and advocated
for rotc to come back in the campus the
question is a good one I you know it is
you know where we are very devoted to
trying to win that RFP I think that
Stanford got a little bit a head start
on us because I think they planned it
and a little bit ahead of time didn't
notify anybody in fact nobody notified
us we've responded as many people of the
trustees know this morning we spent a
lot of time on this this morning talking
about what our response process should
be we feel like we are in very very good
shape with our proposal and we're going
to be as worthy as anybody else to try
to get our way in there and see if we
can't win this as well so the city is
wants to utilize roosevelt island or
governor's island and has offered that
as a space for universities set up a
tech kind of academic base the city is
ultimately interested they say in having
a wider and more diverse economy and so
they want a Silicon Valley kind of
situation here we've said we have a
great engineering school we've got great
related disciplines we've got a
university here we can focus on data and
its gathering and how to use data and so
on and lots of things that were expert
on would love
build and we have manhattanville and
we're ready to do this we don't have the
funds to build this but if you want to
help us we would be thrilled to do that
and we think it would be a great benefit
to the economy no question on the merits
we should win and we'll see how he's
totally right unamerican and frankly you
know I don't think the city was i think
that they weren't straightforward willis
i think they were working a little bit
for proposals behind the scenes and when
other people were interested i think
that they were surprised so funny
housekeeper demora they are dean of our
our engineering school rallied some
alumni and we are well on the way
another question so let me just say one
of the things if Stanford is chosen by
the city to set up a base on Roosevelt
Island or in the city we will be fine in
fact there will be lots of benefits for
us and as I say all the time Harvard is
better for MIT and vice versa Stanford
is better from Berkeley and vice versa
we did not shy away from academic
competition we thrive in it and there's
no reason why that wouldn't be true